[موسيقى]
حصد هذه الليله معي انا ابي عاصي مرحبا
بكم في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من موسكو حيث اعلنت
روسيا استراتيجيه جديده لسياسه الخارجيه
في اجواء الخلافات المتصاعده المرتبطه
بالنزاع في اوكرانيا
الى نيويورك حيث تجري الترتيبات لمثول
دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه الجنائيه في
حدث غير مسبوق لرئيس امريكي سابق
الى الخرطوم وحاله من الترقب والغموض
السياسي بخصوص العمليه الانتقاليه في ضوء
الخلافات خلافات الساعات الاخيره
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في وثيقه تذكر باجواء الحرب البارده موسكو
تتبنى استراتيجيه عالميه جديده مناهضه
للغرب نشيطه تصف واشنطن بالمحرد الرئيسي
للخطي المعادي لروسيا وتعتبر الصين والهند
شريكين رئيسيين وتشدد على تطوير العلاقات
مع افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه
بعد ايام من اعلان موسكو عزمها نشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا قلق في مجلس
الامن الدولي واشنطن تتهم موسكو بالتلاعب
بمواصفته بشبح الصراع النووي لكسب الحرب
فرنسا تعتبر الاعلان الروسي ضربه للحد من
التسلح وروسيا تعتبر الخطوه ردا على نشر
اسلحه نوويه امريكيه في اوروبا
بعد يوم من توجيه اتهام غير مسبوق في
التاريخ الامريكي ترقب لاجراءات تسليم
ترامب نفسه الثلاثاء للوصول امام المحكمه
محامي ترامب يقول ان الرئيس السابق لن يتم
تقييد يديه عندما يسلم نفسه وبايدا يحجم
عن التعليق على الاتهام التاريخي لسلفه
ويقول ان حق الامريكيين في الاحتجاج
السلمي مكفول
في السودان غموض وترقب بشان العمليه
السياسيه القوى المدنيه الموقعه للاتفاق
الايطالي تجتمع لحسم موعد التوقيع على
الاتفاق النهائي واجتماع مرتقب السبت
بتحديد مواقيت جديده لمحطات المرحله
الانتقاليه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التداعيات المحتمله لتوجيه
اتهام رسمي غير مسبوق في التاريخ الامريكي
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وهي خطوه
صنفها ترامب في اطار الاضطهاد السياسي
والتدخل في الانتخابات لاستطاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما هي التداعيات المحتمله
لتوجيه اتهام للرئيس الامريكي السابق
وجاءت النتائج كالتالي 20% قالوا الى
الاتهامه يسهم في خساره ترامب لقاعده
الشعبيه بينما صوت
47% لصالح خيار استثمار ترامب الاتهام
سياسيا اما 33% فرجحوا ان لا يتسبب
الاتهام باي تاثير على
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد الاعلان رسميا عن قائمه المترشحين
ترقب لانتخابات رئاسيه صعبه في تركيا
[موسيقى]
وسط اجواء الخلافات المتصاعده المرتبطه
بالحرب في اوكرانيا اعلنت روسيا اليوم
استراتيجيه جديده لسياسه الخارجيه تقدم
الولايات المتحده والغرب على انهما مصدر
تهديدات وجوديه لموسكو الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه الجديده اعتبرت الصين والهند
شريكين رئيسيين لموسكو وشددت على تطوير
العلاقات مع افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه
وعشره والغرب مصدر تهديدات وجوديه هذا
قليل من كثير في وثيقه من 42 الصفحه
للعقيده الجديده لسياسه الخارجيه الروسيه
اعتمدها الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بتوقيع
مرسوم خاص وبخطاب محمل برسائله لخصومه
النسخه المحدثه لسياسه موسكو مع الخارج
ولدت في سياق حرب تصفها بالهجينه واعاده
توزيع التحالفات المعلنه منها والمستتره
عن الخطوط العريضه للرؤيه الجديده
وملامحها واهدافها اصاب وزير الخارجيه
الروسي في الحديث
في العقيده تتوفر امكانيه اتخاذ اجراءات
متناسقه او غير متناسقه ردا على اي خطوات
عدائيه موجهه ضد روسيا في المفهوم الجديد
للسياسه الخارجيه الروسيه تم تحديد
الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر كمبادر رئيسي
وقائد للخط المعادي لروسيا في العالم وهو
يلقي الضوء على احدى اولويات روسيا التي
تتمثل في ازاله بقايا هيمنه الولايات
المتحده والدول غير الصديقه على الشهود
الدوليه
ومن البنود الاخرى المهمه في السياسه
الجديده وليدتي اجواء تذكر بزمن الحرب
البارده نجد ان روسيا ستسهم في تقليص فرص
البلدان غير الصديقه في اساءه استخدام
مركزها للتاثير في الاقتصاد العالمي ستسعى
موسكو جاهده الى اقامه نظام عالمي يوفر
الامن الموثوق به والفرص المتساويه للجميع
ستستخدم القوات المسلحه لصد ومنعه هجوم
مسلح عليها او على حلفائها تتطلع موسكو
بشكل خاص الى تعمق العلاقات والتنسيق
الشامل مع مركزي القوه الصديقين الصين
والهند
[موسيقى]
على الشرق فتحت الابواب على مصراعيها منذ
مده التقارب بين موسكو وبيجين يزيد ويتوسع
امام اعين الغاضبين والمنتقدين له هذا
التحالف يقابله تحالف غربي يغدق المال
والسلاح على اوكرانيا في حرب كل تفاصيلها
ومنذ البدايه تقول انها بالوكاله محاولات
الغرب عزل روسيا وتعظيم مخاطر تهديدات
التنين الصيني اتت بمفعول غير محبب
لخصومهما قربت بين القوتين رغم خلافاتهما
المتوارثه وتصادم مصالحهما في بعض مناطق
النفوذ ومن وثيقه العقيده الجديده
للخارجيه الروسيه نقرا ان العالم مقبل على
تحالفات وتوازنات وصفقات مغايره تفرضها
حرب حدودها ما بعد اوكرانيا بكثير
ينضم الينا من موسكو السفير اندريه بك
لانوف نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس
ومعنى من واشنطن السفير كورت فولكر السفير
الامريكي السابق لدى حلف النيتو مرحبا
بكما سنبدا معك السيد السفيرت فولكرم من
واشنطن ورد في العقيده الخارجيه الجديده
التي اعلن عنها اليوم في روسيا ان
الولايات المتحده هي المصدر الاساسي
للسياسه المعاديه لروسيا والاولويه لدى
روسيا في المرحله المقبله هي للقضاء على
هيمنه الولايات المتحده كيف ستتعامل
الولايات المتحده مع هذا الامر
نتعامل مع هذا الموقف الروسي منذ زمن بعيد
وهم هاجموا الدول المجاوره ودول مستقله
وايضا حاولوا الهجوم والاضرار بالنيتو اذا
نحن محتاجون على ذلك وهذا يعني اننا ندعم
الحريه والاحرار في كل العالم والاستقرار
والامن في اوروبا وفي كل العالم وهذا يعني
مساعده الاوكرانين على الدفاع عن انفسهم
ودعم
حلف الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي دائما
يعني ما يتحدث به السيد كرت فوكر يكرره
المسؤولون في الغرب الدعمون لاوكرانيا منذ
فتره لا يوجد
سياسات
ضد روسيا بالمطلق ما يجري هو رد فعل على
الهجوم التي قامت به روسيا على اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا هي مجرد جزء من هذه القصه وليست
الجانب الرئيسي فيها
ما يقدمونه الان من خلال اوكرانيا هو
في الجانب المتعلق بالاستراتيجيه هذه
استراتيجيه الجديده هي استجابه لحاله
الهيمنه على العالم والتي تستمر منذ خمسه
او السته او سبع سنوات هذه هذا ردنا على
سياسه الراتب المتحده وحلف النيتو
وهو تحذير
صارم من اننا لن نتردد في استخدام
كافه انواع الاسلحه التي بحوزتنا بما في
ذلك القنابل الذريه من اجل حمايه حقوقنا
السياديه وان نفعل كل ما له علاقه
بمصالحنا الحيويه اذا هذه وثيقه قويه
للغايه
الاجابه
للمحاولات محاولات الغرب والولايات
المتحده للضغط علينا
يعني في هذه الجزئيه الذي اوضحها لنا
السيد السفير اندريه بوكلانوف ان هذه
العقيده تؤكد ان روسيا
قد تلجا الى اي سلاح بما في ذلك سلاح
النووي للمساء للدفاع عن مصالحها في هذه
الجزئيه كيف يمكن للولايات المتحده ان
تتصرف
ليس هناك من يهدد المصالح الاساسيه لروسيا
ولا هناك من يهاجمها ولا لروسيا حق في
هجمات وقتله جيرانها هؤلاء لديهم حق في
بيئه يعيشوا بلادهم وان يدافعوا انفسهم
واذا الله هناك من يداف يهاجم روسيا
بالعكس والصحيح ما يتعلم استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه ليس هناك اي تبرير لاستخدام
السلاح النووي هو مره اخرى يقول لا يستناك
من يهاجم روسيا بالروسيا يترجم الاخرين
فان لكن لو اذا تعرض واذا تعرضوا لهجوم
قبل روسيا وسلاح النووي فطبعا ذلك
الرد قوي جدا جدا سواء كان هجوما على
الغرب او على اوكرانيا لابد ان هناك رد
علي استخدام سلاح نووي وان الولايات
المتحده واضافتنا الكثير من الدول الاخرى
تحث روسيا ان لا تستخدم السلاح النووي طيب
سيد السفير اندريه
تتحدث هذه
الاستراتيجيه او هذه العقيده الخارجيه
الجديده التي تم الاعلان عنها عن التقارب
مع الصين عن تقويه العلاقات مع الهند عن
التقارب مع افريقيا دول الافريقيه ومع
امريكا اللاتينيه بهذا المعنى كيف يمكن ان
نتوقع المرحله المقبله في ظل ايضا الحديث
عن
يعني هذا هذا التوتر الكبير مع الولايات
المتحده تصفها العقيده بالحرب الهجين مع
الولايات المتحده والغرب
في الحقيقه نحن لدينا الان
مصطلح سياسي جديد وهو غالبيه الارض او
كوكب الارض فهناك مليار
موجود في سكان من مليار في العالم
[موسيقى]
يعانون من ما تقوم بهاتر المتحده عندما
تتصرف وكانها تملك كوكب الارض او انها
شرطي كوكب الارض عقليه استعماريه
كولونياليه لهذا السبب نحن في
استراتيجيتنا الجديده هذه نتحدث عن
امكانيه تحالفات جديده ضد محاولات امريكا
فرضها هيمنتها والغرب بفرض هيمنتهم ولفرض
حكمهم للعالم
هذه الاستراتيجيه الاستعماريه للغرب يجب
ان يقضى عليها وسوف نقوم بذلك سوف نقضي
عليها في قادم الايام باختصار
سوف نقضي عليها لان من مصلحه غالبيه سكان
الارض
تنطبق وتتطابق مع مصلحتنا ضد عدواني الغرب
اما فيما يتعلق بما يسمى بالحرب في
اوكرانيا بقدر يتعلق الامر بذلك نحن نرى
ذلك استمرارا
لنراها
امتداد للحرب العالميه الثانيه والحرب ضد
الناسيه وهذه القوه النازيه سنفعل ما
فعلناه بالحرب العالميه الثانيه
سنستس هذا
الضرر وسوف نحرر اوكرانيا
اذا هذه العقيده تتحدث عن التقارب مع
الصين التقارب مع الهند
تقارب مع دول الافريقيه مع امريكا
اللاتينيه ويقول لنا السفير اندريه ان
هناك يبدو رهان على ان هذه اغلبيه في
الكره الارضيه وتتشارك مع موسكو بمستويات
متفاوته بهذا الهدف
المسمى القضاء على الهيمنه الامريكيه كيف
تتعامل امريكا مع ذلك وهل يقلقها هذا مثل
هكذا تقارب بين هذه الدول
الواقع هذا مجرد خيال روسي هذا الكلام لا
اعتقد ان الصين مهتمه بحد كبير بخيالات
تصورات روسيا فلديها مشاريع الخاصه وكذلك
الهند فكليهما
عارضانا روسيا في استخدام السلاح النووي
ولا يريدان ولا يعجبهم هذا التوجه
الاستعماري لروسيا في السيطره على الدول
الاخرى وحكمها او محوها من الوجود
وبالتالي يعتقد ان روسيا تقوم باشياء تقول
كشاء كثيره لكن دون القيام بشيء ملموس او
حقا لا يمكن تطبيقه
السفير الامريكي السابق لدى حلف الناتو
ومن موسكو السفير اندريه بك لانوف نائب
رئيسي جمعيه دبلوماسيين الروس شكرا جزيلا
لكم
[موسيقى]
في مجلس الامن اليوم حذرت ايزومي
وكيله الامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون
نزع السلاح من ان خطر استخدام سلاح نووي
في الوقت الحالي اعلى من اي وقت مضى منذ
الحرب البارده جاء ذلك في الجلسه التي دعت
اليها اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
والبانيا بشان
نيه روسيا نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا
ان خطر استخدام سلاح نووي اعلى حاليا من
اي وقت مضى منذ الحرب البارده تمثل الحرب
في اوكرانيا المثال الاكثر حده لهذا الخطر
ان غياب الحوار والتاكل هيكل نزع السلاح
الى جانب الخطاب الخطير والتهديدات
المستتره هي دوافع رئيسيه لهذا الخطر
الوجودي المحتمل من اجل امننا الجماعي
اجدد تاكيد دعوه الامين العام الاتحاد
الروسيه والولايات المتحده للعوده الى
التنفيذ الكامل لمعاهده ستارت الجديده
وبدء المفاوضات بشان خليفتها من جانبها
قال روبرت وود نائب المندوبه الامريكيه في
مجلس الامن ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين يصعد سلوك روسيا الخطير والمزعزع
للاستقرار من خلال التهديد بنشر الاسلحه
النوويه في بيلاروسيا حسب تعبيره
ممتاز
لا يريد ان تمتلك اوكرانيا القدره على
الدفاع عن نفسها ضد الدبابات الروسيه
دعونا نقول انه لن يكون من الضروري امداد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والمعادله الدفاعيه اذا
لم تكن روسيا قد شنت غزو واسع النطاق على
اوكرانيا اعلان الرئيس بوتين في الخامس
والعشرين من مارس الذي اشار فيه الى ان
نيته نجري اسلحه نوويه في بيلاروسيا لا
يتعلق بتقاسم الاعباء النوويه لا توجد
اسباب موثوقه تتعلق بالدفاع لروسيا لوضع
اسلحه نوويه في بيلاروسيا
في المقابل انتقد المندوب الروسي في مجلس
الامن فاسيلين مواقف الدول الغربيه اذا
قرار روسيا نقل اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه الى
بيلاروسيا واشار الى نشر اسلحه نوويه
امريكيه في اوروبا
هناك منطق لشركائنا الغربيين السابقين وهو
ان روسيا مسؤوله عن كل العلل في عالم
اليوم لكننا نتحدث هنا عن امور خطيره تؤثر
في امن كوكبنا باكمله نتعاون مع بيلاروسيا
دون انتهاك التزاماتنا الدوليه فيما يتعلق
بعدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه الرئيس بوتين
كان واضحا بشان حقيقه اننا لا نتحدث عن
نقل اسلحه نوويه نحن نتحدث عن نقل مجمعات
الصواريخ التكتيكيه التشغيليه الى
بيلاروسيا وصواريخ اسكندر واعاده تجهيز
الطائرات البيلاروسيه وبناء منشاه تخزين
خاصه للاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه على اراضي
بيلاروسيا سيكون هذا كله تحت السيطره
الروسيه
تعليقا على جلسه مجلس الامن التي ناقشت
نقل اسلحه نوويه روسيه الى بيلاروسيا قال
مندوب الب انيا في مجلس الامن الدولي فريد
خوجه في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره ان موسكو
لم تقدم سوى التبريرات والاعذار في جلسه
مجلس الامن ووصف خوجا الخطوه بانها
استفزاز روسي جديد لخلق مزيد من التوتر
كما في جلسات سابقه ما سمعناه كان مجرد
تبريرات لهذا التحرك الروسي هذه اول عمليه
من هذا النوع بعد اتفاقيه حظر انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه من بلد لاخر كثير من
الدول عبرت عن قلقها من ذلك وليس الدول
الغربيه فحسب هذا السلوك استفزاز الروسي
اخر لتصعيد الوضع وزياده التوتر ويتفق مع
انتهاكات روسيا لميثاق الامم المتحده
والقانون الدولي منذ اكثر من سنه
[موسيقى]
يوم من ردود الفعل والترقب الامني والسجال
القانوني في الولايات المتحده بعد قرار
هيئه محلفين كبرى توجيه لائحه اتهام ضد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
نيويورك تستعد لوصول الرئيس السابق بعد غد
الاثنين قبل مثوله امام المحكمه الثلاثاء
محامي ترامب يقول ان الرئيس السابق لن يتم
تقييد يديه عندما يسلم نفسه وفي البيت
الابيض احجم الرئيس جو بايدن عن التعليق
على لائحه الاتهام الموجهه لترامب لكنه
قال انه يدعم حق الامريكيين في الاحتجاج
السلمي دون الخوض في التكهنات بشان ما
سيحدث
عاصفه الانتقادات والاتهامات من المعسكر
الجمهوري في مجملها تضفي طابعا سياسيا على
القضيه وبدا لافتا خلالها ان الجمهوريين
في مجلس النواب اعلى صوتا من نظرائهم في
مجلس الشيوخ وان منافسيه في الانتخابات
المقبله اصطفوا معه ولكن على نحو لا يقوض
دعواهم بان ترامب لم يعد ملائما للرئاسه
او اهلا لقياده
الحزبها حريه
لا اعتقد ان هذه الاتهامات ستضر به لاننا
لسنا ديمقراطيه فعاله فالحزب الجمهوري
اختزل في شخص واحد ويمكن رؤيه ذلك من خلال
ردود الفعل على لائحه الاتهام بما في ذلك
بعض قاده الحزب الذين كانوا ينتقدون ترامب
في الماضي ووصفوا هذه المحاكمه الان
بالسياسيه
امتناع الرئيس بايدن عن التعليق بشان
القضيه قابله احتفاء من فريق واسع من
الديمقراطيين يرى في توجيه تهم جنائيه الى
ترامب اخيرا انتصارا للقانون فيما لم يخفي
فريق اخر امتعاضه لان التهم جاءت في قضيه
يعدونها الاقل اهميه ما قد يؤثر سلبا في
قضايا اخرى يرونها اكثر خطوره وعلى راسها
الهجوم على الكونجرس والوثائق السريه
وانتخابات ولايه جورجيا الولايات المتحده
امام اختبار جديد بعد توجيه تهم جنائيه
الى رئيس سابق في خطوه غير مسبوقه والجدل
المتصاعد بهذا الشان لا يعمق حاله
الانقسام السياسي فحسب بل قد يزعزع ثقه
الامريكيين او فريق منهم بنزاهه النظامين
القضائي والانتخابي
مرض هاشم الجزيره نيويورك
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور جون مالكم
رئيس قسم الشؤون القانونيه والقضائيه في
مؤسسه
عندما يتم توجيه لائحه اتهام وفي هذه
الحاله توجيه لائحه اتهام لاول مره في
التاريخ لرئيس امريكي السابق ماذا يقول
لنا هذا عن قوه الادله والبراهين لدى
المدعي العام
[موسيقى]
محاميه والذي قدمه الاموال والذي ايضا قدم
التقريرا حول الموضوع وايضا
ظهر امام الكونغرس الى
مجله اسمه النيم هاكر ايضا هو قدم اموال
اخرى للسيده اخرى لمحاوله اسكاتها عن عن
الحديث عن علاقه تقول انه كانت لديها مع
الرئيس السابق طيب الان يحاول الجمهوريون
القول انما يجري هو استغلال للقضاء قال
ذلك ترامب ويقول ذلك ايضا مسؤولون في
الحزب الجمهوري في الكونجرس وفي مجلس
الشيوخ كيف يمكن ابعاد هذه المحاكمه عن
الاستقطاب السياسي الجاري في الولايات
المتحده
صعب جدا في هذه البيئه الحاليه ذلك هذه
لاول مره ان يكون هناك رئيس سابق موجه له
تهم بجرائم في بلد مقسم كثيرا جزءا سياسيا
في نهايه المطاف لابد ان يقدم الادعاء
العامه ادله شديده بان الرئيس مذنب دون اي
شيء واعتقد ستسمح للفرصه ذلك يقدم هذه
الادله ولكن لابد من قول من كل التحقيقات
الجاريه حاليا وهناك علقه تحقيقان اخران
ضد الرئيس السابق هذا التحقيق يبدو هو
الاضعف فهو فهو تهمه غير اعتياديه هذه
الواقع تعتبر جنحه او مخالفه قانونيه
بموجب القانون الا وهي مساله وضع
معلومات خاطئه في سجلات تجاريه وهي تعتبر
لان هذا مثل هذه الجنحه هي كانت لتغطيه
على تمويل غير قانوني ضمن اموال الحمله
الانتخابيه وهذه تهمه فيدراليه وليس
الولايه واحده وان
لمن يحقق في مثل هذه الجرعه هي وزاره
العدل ولجنه الفتره الفيدراليه للانتخابات
هم الذين يدرسون مثل هذه المسائل
ويقومنا بتحقيقهم وقد غلقوا اغلقه
دقيقه من دون توجيهاتهم اما المدعي العام
هذا براك فانه احيا هذه التهمه اللي يقول
انها جريمه ضد الدوله وهي تهمه غير
اعتياديه
وسيكون لدى الرئيس السابق الكثير من
الدفاعات يمكنها يقدمهم لنفعلين ننظر
وتكون محاكمه امام هيئه محلفين من مدينه
نيويورك وهي منطقه ليست
علاقاتها جيده او مرحبه بالرئيس ترامب
السابق طيب دكتور جون عندما نعرف ماذا
تتضمن لائحه الاتهام الموجهه لترام كيف
يمكن ان ينعكس ذلك على حمله ترامب وعلى
هذا السجال السياسي الدائر
متنبئ سياسي لكن بالتاكيد ان
مؤيديه وهم كثيرون غاضبون غضبا شديدا
ويقومون بالتظاهر ووقوف خلفه واذا كان
الجمهور العام يعتقد ان الرئيس سابق يعامل
معامله غير عادله من قبل النظام القضائي
فذلك قد يؤدي الى المزيد من الداعمين او
المؤيدين للترامب ولكن نعرف كم من الاشخاص
المستقيمين هم ليسوا حاليا معجبين بالرئيس
ترامب كيف سيكون رد فعلهم لكن هذا الواقع
هو التطور
كبير جدا والعواطف والمشاعر الشديده في
الجانبين شكرا لك
رئيس قسم الشؤون القانونيه والقضائيه في
مؤسسه زهره جراونديشن
جنائيه هو سابقه في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده لكن في السياق الداخلي الحالي
يقول انصار ترامب انه قد يستفيد من ذلك في
تعزيز صداره للمنافسه على ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري حيث يكرس سرديه الاضطهاد التي
يروج لها ترامب في المقابل قد تخلق هذه
التهم متاعب في الانتخابات العامه اذا حظي
بترشيح الجمهوريين ويواجه ترامب جمله من
التحقيقات والقضايا نجمل اهمها في التقرير
التالي
ما كان بالامس تخمينات صار اليوم حقيقه
دونالد ترامب يواجه بيتها من جنائيه في
سابقه تاريخيه في غمره الحمله الانتخابيه
للحصول على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري الرئيس
الامريكي السابق الذي سبق لاعلن انه
سيواجه الاعتقال على موعد مع السلطات
القضائيه في ولايه نيويورك ما تزال تفاصيل
القضيه تحت غطاء السريه لكن وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه تتحدث عن قضيه دفع مبالغ ماليه
لاسكات ممثله اباحيه كانت على علاقه
بالترامب في مخالفه لقانون تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه وقانونيه سجلات الضرائب توجيه
التهم على اهميته قد لا يؤثر في حضور
ترامب الانتخابيه بل يقول محامي الرئيس
السابق ان الاعتقال قد يقنع فئه من
الامريكيين ان الدوله العميقه تمنعن في
اضطهاده وقانونيا لا تمنع النصوص المعتمده
في الولايات المتحده المساجين من الترشح
بل واداره البلاد من الزنزانه في حال فوزه
في الانتخابات
تواجه ترامب الطامح للعوده الى البيت
الابيض في خريف العام المقبل رئيسا
للولايات المتحده جمله من التحقيقات منها
ما هو مدني ومنها ما هو جنائي واخرى تتعلق
بالامن القومي ابرز القضايا المدنيه ما
تحقق فيه ولايه نيويورك في شبهه تقليل
ممتلكاته وتضخيم نفقاته لاسباب تتعلق
بالتهرب الضريبي والقيام بالعكس لاقتراض
الاموال من البنوك اما السلطات التحقيق في
ولايه جورجيا فتنظر في مزاعم محاوله ترامب
وحلفائه التدخل في نتائج انتخابات سنه
2020 وفيدراليا يحقق مكتب التحقيقات الاف
بي اي في اداره ترامب للوثائق السريه التي
كانت في عهدته اثناء ممارسه مهامه وسبق
لفريق من المكتب ان اغار على مقر اقامته
في مارلاجو فلوريدا حيث استعاد عشرات
الوثائق عدد منها على اعلى درجات السريه
وبعضها يحتوي اسرار النوويه وكل هذه
التحقيقات مستمره خلف الستار ولم يتكشف من
تفاصيلها سوى القليل
[موسيقى]
في السودان قلى عضو في لجنه الصياغه
النهائيه للجزيره ان توقيع الاتفاق
النهائي في موعدها المقرر غدا السبت سيكون
صعبا في ظل تباعد شقه الخلاف بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع بشان عمليه الدمج
والاصلاح العسكري فضلا عن ملاحظات للاطراف
على مسوده الاتفاق النهائي نفسها لم تناقش
بعد بسبب بروز الخلافات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع وتوقع العضو الذي فضل عدم الكشف عن
اسمه تاجيل المواقيت الزمنيه الخاصه
بتوقيع الاتفاق النهائي وبدء تشكيل مؤسسات
الحكم الانتقالي في حدود ايام قليله فقط
حسب تعبيره وكان المتحدث الرسمي باسم
العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف قد قال
للجزيره انه اذا لم تحسم كل القضايا سيدعى
الى اجتماع موسع لمناقشه تعديل الجدول
الزمني لاكمال هياكل السلطه المدنيه
من جهه قال المتحدث باسم المجلس المركزي
لقوى الحريه والتغيير شهاب ابراهيم ان
لجنه صياغه توصيات ورشه الاصلاح العسكري
المكونه من مدنيين وعسكريين ستعكف اليوم
على دراسه ملاحظات جميع المكونات التي
شاركت في الورشه واكد ابراهيم في حديثه
للجزيره عدم حدوث اختراق حتى الان في
القضايا المتعلقه بعدد السنوات المطلوبه
لاتمام عمليه دمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش وبشان الالتزام بتوقيع الاتفاق
النهائي غدا السبت افاد المتحدث ان ذلك
رهن بحدوث تقدم في النقاط العالقه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم فيصل محمد صالح
مستشار رئيس الوزراء السابق ومن الخرطوم
ايضا معنا مجد عبد العزيز الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بكما سيد فيصل محمد صالح هل
اصبحت توقيع على الاتفاق النهائي بحكم
المؤجل باعتقادك
بالتاكيد بقراءه ما حدث في اليوم الاخير
لورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري ومن المؤكد
انه لن يمكن التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي
غدا رغم انه 90% من الاتفاق تقريبا تم
الاتفاق عليها المسواد الرئيسي وعده قبل
ثلاثه ايام ووزعت على القيادات اربعه ورش
تم قراءتها وقراءه الملحقات بها وستلحق
بروتوكولات اضافيه تبقت الجزئيه الخاصه
بالاصلاح الامني والعسكري وحتى في الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري نقطه الخلاف واحده ومحدده
ولذلك اعتقد انه لابد ان يتم تاجيل الجدول
ليومين او ثلاثه هذا تقريبا ما سيحدث الى
ان تحسم هذه النقطه الخلافيه
والخلاف ده قديم وموجود وهو ليس خلافا
فنيا يعني اذا حاولنا ان نقرا حول المده
وخلاف سياسي لانه تباعدت المواقف السياسيه
بين قياده القوات المسلحه وقياده الدعم
السريع ولذلك في ظل هذا الخلاف السياسي اي
نقطه صغيره يمكن ان يتم عليها خلاف يعني
مساله سنوات الدم هذه مساله فنيه كان من
الممكن ان يجلس خبراء فنيين ويمكن ان
يستعينوا بتجارب دول اخرى ويغدر المده
اللازمه لعمليه الدمج بما فيها من
اصلاح بما فيها من توحيد الكوادر
والقيادات بما فيها من توحيد القوات
العسكريه والتسريح من هم غير مؤهلين للدم
هذه قضيه فنيه هنا خبرات اقليميه ودوليه
فيها تمت كان من اليمن يمكن مناقشته ولكن
للتباعد المواقف السياسيه صارت هي نقطه
خلاف ولذلك اعتقد انها تحتاج الى مزيد من
الوقت والجهد حتى يتم تجاوزها سيد مجدي
عبد العزيز باي عين تراقبون هذا المشهد
شكرا جزيلا اتفق مع ضيفك الكريم بانه
يستحيل غدا ان يتم توقيع على الاتفاق
الايطالي استند في ذلك على بيان الجيش في
الليل قبل الماضيه انه في انتظار اعمال
اللجان الفنيه التي تنظر في المساله
الفنيه في دمج
وتكوين جيش موحد كذلك نقول انه المكون
العسكري القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
التزموا او التزمتاه بالابتعاد عن العمل
السياسي في الفتره الانتقاليه الان ايضا
الظهر هناك ان القوه الحريه والتغيير
والدعم السريع
سيبقيان ظهري بعض هذا ظهير سياسي لقوه
عسكريه وهذا ظهير عسكري لقوه سياسيه
بالتالي الوحيد الذي يستطيع ان يقول اني
اقف على مسافه واحده من جميع القوى
السياسيه هو الجيش وليس الدعم السريع لذلك
اذا مضت هذه
العمليه بهذه الطريقه تطويل امد دمج الدعم
السريع تدخل البلد في مشكله اخرى وتعقيدات
كبيره وهذا بالضبط هو خلاف بين القيادتين
وظهر هذا الخلاف منذ منذ وقت ان المكون
العسكريه كتله عسكريه واحده ولكن هناك
لسانين سياسيين يتحدثان عن المشهد السياسي
طيب سيد فيصل هذا هذه الاشكاليه وذكرت
انها اشكاليه فنيه كما وصفتها هل يمكن ان
تخفي في طياتها ما هو ابعد من ذلك ما قد
حقيقه يهدد هذا الاتفاق في المرحله
المقبله
بالتاكيد هي ليست تخفي هي من الواضح جدا
انها خلاف سياسي يتلبس لبوس القضيه الفنيه
كما ذكرت لو الطرفان راى ان قضيه فنيه كان
ممكن كما ذكرت يجلس خبراء فنيين يستعيدوا
حتى بتجاربه دول اخرى ويرى ما هي الوقت
المناسب لاجراء التحليل لكن القضيه
الاساسيه موقف سياسي بالنسبه الى القوات
المسلحه والدعم السريع ومشاركه معا في
انقلاب 25 اكتوبر
هذه الفكره كانت القوات المسلحه وقيادات
القوات المسلحه العليا يؤدون واجب التحيه
للفريق محمد حمدان حميدتي هم الذين عينوه
دائما لمجلس السياده هم الذين عدلوا قانون
الدعم
من ذلك سيد فيصل يعني يعني انا قصدت من
وراء السؤال عن ان هذه القضيه التي وصفتها
بالفنيه هل يمكن ان تؤثر في المدى البعيد
على الهدف الاساسي من الاتفاق النهائي وهو
النقل السلطه من العسكريين الى المدنيين
بالتاكيسه تؤثر هي ستعرغل العمل لانه اذا
لم يتم حسمها ستعرقل العمليه السياسيه
كلها لكن انا المريض اقوله انه هي وراءها
هدف سياسي انه التباعد الذي حصل في الموقف
السياسي ضايق القياده العسكريه القوات
المسلحه لم يعد المكونه العسكري موحدا
ومنضبطا لانه ببساطه شديده منذ 25 اكتوبر
الفريق البرهان كان يملك السلطه المطلقه
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه وحتى القضائيه لو
اراد ان يضم الدعم السريع كان بامكاني ان
يصدر قرارا بتعديل القانون بضم الدعم
السريع باي شكل هو الذي هو حل مجلس
السياده حل مجلس الوزراء اخرج الحريه
والتغيير ابغى الكتله المسلحه عدل كثير
جدا من القوانين كان يمكن ان يصدر قرارا
لو اراد في ذلك الوقت لانهم كانوا حلفاء
لم يكن يريد ذلك بحل الدعم السريع او يعني
اعطاء جدول زمني
لحل ودمج الدعم السريع لكنه ابغى ذلك ثم
اراد ان يستغله سياسيا في هذه النقطه انا
اعتقد ان القضيه السياسيه هي القضيه
الاساسيه سياسيه هناك اطراف في الغياده
القوات المسلحه ترف ض الاتفاق الايطالي
ولا تريد المضي به ولذلك تتخذ من هذه
النقطه حجه حتى تبطل كل الاتفاق السياسي
اذا كان هذا هو الوضع كيف تتوقع ان يتم حل
كل هذه الاشكاليه الكبيره في غضون ايام
والذهاب نحو التوقيع النهائي في غضون ايام
كما ذكرت لنا
انا اعتقد ان الضغوط المحليه والضغوط
الاقليميه والضغوط الدوليه ستؤدي الى ذلك
هناك الانضغوط كبيره على كل الاطراف لانه
كما ذكرت في نظر الجميع انه القضايا
الاساسيه الكبيره معظمها تم الاتفاق عليها
فلماذا الان التوقف عند نقطه جزئيه فنيه
كانوا يمكن حلها بسهوله عبر اجتماع او
اجتماعيا او ثلاثه اذا كان الحريه
والتغيير او حتى الغول
نعم تفضل بسرعه
انا اردت ان اقول انه القوه المدنيه هي
اساسا المطالب بدمج الدعم السريع وحله هذه
مطالب القوه الجماهيريه منذ 11 ابريل 2019
الفريق البرهان وقياده القوات المسلحه صلي
يدافع عن الدعم السريع ويقولوا انه جزء من
القوات المسلحه فالقوات المدنيه لو هناك
امكانيه غدا لدمج الدعم السريع وتسريحه
مؤكد انها ترحب بذلك في هذا تحقيق
متطلبات الثوره والاشعارات التي رفعتها
الجماهير في الثوره في ظل تعقيدات هذا
الخلاف بين المكونين العسكريين الجيش
والدعم السريع باعتقادك اين تمضي الامور
السؤال نعم تفضل سيد مجدي عبد العزيز
نعم طبعا انا اقول انه مساله الدمج هذا
هدف كبير وهدف رئيسي لانه مساله الدمج غير
معني فقط به الدعم السريع ايضا معنيه به
الحركات الحركات الكفاح المسلحه التي وقعت
عن الاتفاق جبهه وهناك بروتوكول للترتيبات
الامنيه يجب ان يوفى به صحيح الموقف الدعم
السريع ما قبل 25 اكتوبر كان في الموقف
الاخر لقوه الحريه والتغيير وسمعنا
تصريحات القائد حميتي في اوقات كثيره جدا
عن الانتخابات وعن النقور الحريه والتغيير
تريد تطويل امد الفتره الفتره الانتقاليه
لكن حصل طبعا تغييرات صحيحه تغيرات سياسيه
وتغييرات في المواقف وحصل تقارب او تحالف
بين الدعم السريع وهذه القوه الحريه
والتغيير كل هذه المعطيات الان هي التي
حتمت ان يتم الدمج قبل التوقيع على
الاتفاق الاطاري وان تذهب العمليه
السياسيه وتاتي الفتره الانتقاليه بجي
واحد قومي موحد يحمل فتره الانتقاليه حتى
مرحله مرحله الانتخابات كما قلت وايضا
طبعا تحدث الفريق البرهان بان القوات
المسلحه والمكونه العسكري والجيش الواحد
لن يخضع الا لحكومه منتقبه لذلك لابد الان
من مساله الدمج وان يكون المكون العسكري
موجود بوظيفته في حمايه الفتره الانتقاليه
وحمايه التحول الانتقالي وبالتالي يفتح
الطريق لتكوين الحكومه
مدنيه تقود فتره الانتقاليه لمرحله
الانتخابات شكرا لكما من الخرطوم مجدي عبد
العزيز الكاتب والمحلل السياسي والسيد
فيصل عبد محمد صالح مستشار رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق شكرا لكمما
[موسيقى]
الى تركيا حيث حدد المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات القائمه النهائيه للمتنافسين
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره في الرابع
عشر من مايو ايار المقبل وضمه القائمه
اربعه مرشحين سيتنافسون على مقعد الرئاسه
اربعه مرشحين رسميا في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه المقرره في الرابعه عشر
من مايو المقبل الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان وابرز خصومه السياسيين رئيس حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كمالك ورئيس حزب البلد
محرم جاه ومرشح وتحالف الاجداد سننوغان
درسنا كل الاعتراضات التي وصلتنا وفق مواد
دستوري وقوانين الجمهوريه ونتيجه لذلك
وباجماع الاصوات فان القائمه النهائيه
للمرشحين ستضم كمالك الجدارلو ومحرم جا
ورجب طيب اردوغان وسنان اوغان
في الوصول الى السباق الرئاسي يعني
حصولهما على نسبه من اصوات الناخبين ما
يزيد من ضبابيه صوره المنافسه الرئاسيه
امام الرئيس اردوغان في انتخابات 2018
وحصل حينها على اكثر من 30% من الاصوات ما
يزيد احتمال ان تذهب الانتخابات الى جوله
ثانيه في حال انتهج اداء جيدا في الايام
المقبله ينتهج اردوغان في حملته
الانتخابيه نمطا ساكنا بعيدا عن الاناشيد
والاحتفالات بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
ويعد باعاده بناء مئات الالاف من الوحدات
السكنيه ويقدم وعودا اخرى اما زعيم تحالف
المعارضه كمال كليتشار اولو فيعد بتحسين
وضع البلاد وتخليصها مما تسميها المعارضه
سلطه الرجل الواحد ويعد انجا بضمان حريه
الاعلام واستقلاليه القضاء وتحسين الوضع
الاقتصادي وتمثل اعاده من هم الحمايه
المؤقته واللاجئين والمهاجرين غير
الشرعيين الى بلادهم البنده الابرز على
اجنده المرشح اوغان
في السنوات الاخيره تحاول اردوغان الى
شخصيه مؤثره دوليا اضافه الى سجل الداخلي
في حين يركز المرشحون الثلاثه الاخرون على
الوضع الداخلي
تشير قائمه المرشحين الاربعه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه الى ان المنافسه على منصب الرئيس
ستكون صعبه وقد اعلن المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات انه في حال لم يحسم اسم الرئيس
يوم الانتخاب فان جوله للاعاده ستجرى بعده
باسبوعين بين المرشحين الحاصلين على اعلى
الاصوات المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره انقره
[موسيقى]
الى الهجمات الاسرائيليه على اهداف
ايرانيه في الاراضي السوريه والتي تصاعدت
في الفتره الاخيره ضواحي دمشق شهدت الهجوم
الاحدث تحديدا فجر اليوم واعلن الحرس
الثوري الايراني مقتل ميلاد حيدري احد
مستشاريه العسكريين في سوريا في غاره
اسرائيليه في مزيد من التفاصيل قالت وكاله
الانباء السوريه ان الدفاعات الجويه
السوريه تصدت لما وصفته بعنوان اسرائيلي
على موقع في ريف العاصمه دمشق فجر اليوم
هي الضربه الاسرائيليه الثانيه قرب دمشق
في اقل من اربع وعشرين ساعه بعد غاره
اسرائيليه اسفلت عن اصابه عسكريين سوريين
ليلى الاربعاء قرب العاصمه السوريه وفي
الثاني والعشرين من مارس اذار تسبب هجوم
اسرائيلي في مدينه حلب بشمال سوريا في
تعطل خدمات مطار حلب لفتره وجيزه وقالت
مصادر ان الضربه اصابت مخزن اسلحه ايرانيه
داخل ايران نفسها وتحديدا مدينه اصفهان
وكشفت ايران عن هجوم بطائره مسيره على
موقع عسكري الثامن والعشرين من يناير
الماضي وقالت ان مرتزقه اسرائيليين نفذوه
شنت اسرائيل خلال الاعوام الماضيه مئات
الضربات الجويه في سوريا طالت مواقع للجيش
السوري واهدافا ايرانيه واخرى لحزب الله
اللبناني بينها مستودعات اسلحه وذخائر على
الرغم من ان اسرائيل لا تعلن المسؤوليه عن
هجمات بعينها الا ان رئيس الوزراء السابق
نفتالي بنت كشف في يوليو من العام الماضي
عما اسماه عقيده الاخطبوط تقضي استراتيجيه
او عقيده الاخطبوط باستهداف ايران بشكل
مباشر وليس فقط استهداف وكلاء او اذرع او
ما يمكن تسميته باهداف تابعه لايران في
المنطقه وتهدف عقيده الاخطبوط الى نقل
معركه اسرائيل ضد ايران الى الاراضي
الايرانيه بعد سنوات من استهداف مواقع
وشخصيات خارج ايران في اماكن مثل سوريا
هذه الاستراتيجيه المتفق عليها بين
المستويين السياسي والعسكري في تقضي بشن
مزيدا من الهجمات لتقويض القدرات
الايرانيه
ويشير خبراء الى ان هجوم اصفهان في يناير
الماضي دليل على ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ملتزم بتبني
عقيده الاخطبوط لسلفيه بنت ويائير لبيد
ينضم الينا من مدينه ليدز في بريطانيا
الدكتور علم صالح استاذ دراسات ايران وشرق
الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه
مرحبا بك دكتور علم صالح ماذا يعني اعتراف
ايران بكل هذه الهجمات
بالاستهداف الذي حصل بالامس لمستشار عسكري
للحرس الثوري الايراني
طهران تعرف جيدا ان
تل ابيب تنتفع من تصعيد التوترات في في
المنطقه وهجمات الاسرائيليه في سوريا وحتى
في داخل ايران ليست الا خطط تكتيكيه
استفزازيه ولا تجدي شيئا لان راينا ان
الهجمات الاسرائيليه ان كانت في سوريا او
او في ايران ضد بعض مراكز او منشات
النوويه لا تغير السياسات الايرانيه
الاقليميه ولا تغير سياساتها النوويه ولا
تقوض دورها الامني في سوريا
الطهران تعرف جيدا ان اسرائيل تعاني الان
من الثلاث ازمات هامه جدا داخليا واقليميا
ودوليا داخليا هنالك احتجاجات وانشقاقات
عميقه كبيره في داخل السوري في داخل
اسرائيل
ونتنياهو يريد ان يلفت الانتباه من
الاوضاع المتداوله داخليا
العدو الخارجي اي في سوريا
اقليميا اسرائيل ايضا غلقه جدا من التحسين
العلاقات بين ايران والدول العربيه
ودمشق والدول العربيه ايضا
فهذا الشيء لا
يجدي شيئا لاسرائيل بلبل تقلقها كثيرا
دوليا هنالك ايضا انشقاقات وهي اضطرابات
بين واشنطن
الرئيس بايدن علاقاته علاقاته معنى ثاني
هو علاقات
ليست
قريبه جدا فهنالك مشاكل
تريد من خلال تصعيد هذه الاضطرابات ان
تورط امريكيين
لمواجهه ايران في داخل سوريا ومن ثم توريط
امريكا لمواجهه ايران بسرعه عسكريه
وبالتالي في ظل كل هذه الصوره كيف يخدم
ايران هذا الاعتراف بان احد المستشارين
العسكريين الحرس الثوري الايراني قضى في
هذه الغاره امس الغاره الاسرائيليه
طهران كانت دائما تعترف ان هنالك
اخصائيين في
امور الامنيه ايرانيين موجودين في سوريا
وايران تريد ان تقول ان ان الايران ايضا
دفعت ثمن
بعناصرها
بجنوده في سوريا في نفس الوقت وان ولكن ان
هذا الامر على اي قاتل واحد او اثنين من
الحره من الحرس الثوري لا يجدي اسرائيل
شيء كثيرا لان ايران تفكر في استراتيجيه
بعيدة المناعه للطوق الامني ضد اسرائيل في
غزه في جنوب لبنان وفي سوريا وطبعا من
خلال الاراضي الايرانيه
طيب الدكتور علم باعتقادك كيف ستتعامل في
المرحله المقبله في ضوء ما قلته ايران مع
هذه الهجمات الاسرائيليه التي تستهدفها من
بين ما تستهدفهم في سوريا
بصراحه
الاستراتيجيه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه في سوريا هي
استراتيجيه
فيها مجازفات كثيره لا نعرف الى اي مدى
ايران لا تجاوب ضد هذه الهجمات ولكن نرى
ان ايران تتخذ سياسه الصبر وتفكر
بالاستراتيجيه بعيده المدى
لتطوق او او في حصار الاسرائيلي امنيا
خارج اراضيها اي في دول الجيران خاصه بعد
تحسين العلاقات انحصل بين ايران ومصر
وايران واردن هذا الامر يغلق الاسرائيليين
اكثر واكثر هجمات
الضئيله الصغيره مثل هذه الهجمات ربما
تقتل نفره ونفران ولكن لا تغير سياسات
الامنيه الايرانيه في في المنطقه شكرا لك
من بريطانيا من ليدزا البريطانيه الدكتور
علم صالح استاذ ودراسات ايران والشرق
الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه
[موسيقى]
الانسان والجفاف عبر العالم في اوروبا
اثاروا الجفاف غير المعتاد في فصل الشتاء
في مناطق من جنوب القاره مخاوف من تكرار
ما حدث في عام 2022 عندما تضرر مليون و940
فدانا اي اكثر من مثلي المتوسط السنوي على
مدى 16 عاما وفقا لاحصاءات المفوضيه
الاوروبيه اثر ازمه جفاف غير مسبوقه قالت
شركه توزيع المياه الحكوميه في تونس اليوم
انها ستقطع المياه الصالحه للشرب لسبع
ساعات يوميا في كل ارجاء البلاد وحذرت
اتحاد الفلاحه من ان موسم حصاد الحبوب في
تونس سيكون كارثيا متوقعا انخفاض المحصول
الى ما بين 200 الف ومئتين وخمسين الف طن
هذا العام مقابل 750 الف طن العام الماضي
الامل كل الامل ان تمر الازمه بسلام على
الجميع شكرا لكم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]